el sueño de llegar a europa sigue
costando miles de vidas cada año más de
3000 personas murieron o desaparecieron
en su intento de cruzar el mar en 2021
1924 de ellos intentaron cruzar el
mediterráneo central y occidental
mientras 1.153 lo hicieron por la ruta
marítima del noreste de áfrica hacia las
islas canarias en el informe publicado
por la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados acnur se evidencia un fuerte
aumento entre 2020 y 2021
ahora si miramos a 2021 en comparación
con 2020 estamos viendo casi una tasa
doble en realidad un doble las muertes
en 2020 2020 para las rutas el número de
muertos fue de mil 544 y para 2021 fue
de más de 3000 así que es alarmante
solamente la mayor parte de las
travesías en el mar mediterráneo se
realizaron en embarcaciones inflables
que no son aptas para la navegación por
lo que muchas de ellas volcaron o se
pincharon en el trayecto las que toman
la peligrosa vía del atlántico pueden
durar 10 días en el viaje y perderse del
rumbo o desaparecer sin dejar rastro la
pandemia tampoco ha sido una aliada de
los refugiados durante los largos
confinamientos y cierres fronterizos de
2021 muchos en medio de la desesperación
recurrieron a las inseguras redes de
tráfico de personas las rutas terrestres
también implican grandes riesgos por el
sahara están expuestos a ejecuciones
extrajudiciales detenciones ilegales
violencia sexual y otras violaciones de
los derechos humanos la situación en lo
que va del año también es preocupante
para la acnur
desde el comienzo del año hasta el día
de hoy tenemos
478 personas que han muerto o
desaparecido por lo tanto son casi 500 y
solo estamos llegando a mayo y miles de
personas buscan iniciar una nueva vida
en europa lejos de las constantes crisis
que azotan a sus países de origen